the Batman vs Superman Easter eggs that
flew over your head with a running time
of two and a half hours Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice has a lot going
on we've gone over all 153 minutes with
a fine-tooth comb and picked out the
best and biggest Easter eggs to give you
hints of what to look for in the movie
here's a spoiler-filled guide to all the
DC Comics goodies peppered throughout
the film one more time for anyone who's
not paying attention Major Spoilers
ahead still here great let's dive in
dark side is coming
Bruce Wayne's nightmare Vision which
occurs while he's asleep at his bad desk
and sets something major looming on the
DC movie Horizon fans of the comics will
recognize the flying creatures in this
scene as parody the nasty Comics
creatures who serve The Intergalactic
pooper villain known as Darkseid you can
also see darkseid's omega symbol carved
into the ground at the beginning of
Bruce's vision and Luth receives to
directly reference his impending arrival
when he threatens he's coming at the end
of the movie but that's not the only
hint of darkseid's presence we get out
of Batman vs Superman Mother Box when
wonder woman takes a pour through Lex
Luthor's meta human files we get our
best looks yet at the future members of
the Justice League including the flash
Aquaman and Cyborg in particular
Cyborg's origin could be a lab footage
that shows him being booted up for the
first time has even more to offer fans
than just the beginnings of a major
superhero that's because we get a look
at what seems to be a mother box a super
powerful supercomputer ripped right from
the pages of Jack Kirby's new God Saga
just like Batman's vision of the future
the mother box has major ties with
Darkseid and the aliens of new genesis
and apocalypse since it looks like
Cyborg's creation has direct ties to
God's technology just like the new
version of his origin in the comics from
2011. expect the hero to play a pretty
big role in the DC extended Universe
riddle me this Batman's troubled past is
felt more than seen were discussed in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice but
Snyder's fondness for referencing Comics
lore can be seen in the building where
the showdown between the two Heroes goes
down if you look carefully you can spot
what looks a lot like some graffiti left
behind by The Riddler or perhaps some of
this henchmen but if we see him in
future DC movies and Will Jim Carrey
reprise the role
kgb's Lex Luthor has a high-ranking
henchman in Batman vs Superman named
pandatoli canizov played by Khalid
bulvey and although he doesn't look
anything like he does in the comics DC
fans will recognize that as the real
name of the villain known as kg Beast
could we be seeing tonight's EV in a
different form later on considering his
fate in this movie getting exploded
after Batman shoots at the flamethrower
he's wearing on his back it's a good bet
that he'll be more inclined to wear
something closer to his comic book
costume in future appearances assuming
of course he hasn't simply been
incinerated Mercy Braves that's no
ordinary employee bringing sod's corpse
to Lex Luthor fans of Superman the
animated series will recognize the
character of Mercy grave played here by
talakamoto Luther's personal assistant
and bodyguard she became a fan favorite
during the run of the series and it's
exciting to see her brought to the big
screen in such a major movie of course
unless we misunderstood the scene where
she's inside the Senate building that
explodes about halfway through the movie
we might not get much more versy in
future DC built flicks oh well
batallo before the movie came out it was
rumored that Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice would feature an appearance by
Metallo the comics villain who goes from
Life as a soldier to a life of crime
after having his body rebuilt with
Kryptonite powered cyborg parts that did
quite happen probably because of how
many other details were crammed into its
running time yet if you watch the
closing credits you'll see that one of
the technicians demonstrating the
effects of kryptonite in Luther's lab is
named an unveil which just happens to be
the name of the scientist to build
batallo watch for the metal man to make
his debut in a future DC extended
Universe fill
Jimmy Olsen as much fun as Zack Snyder
clearly has calling back to the comics
he isn't above changing things up when
it suits in case in point Jimmy Olsen
brief and ultimate tragic cameo in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justin Early
in the film when Lois travels through
the fictional country of Naomi Africa
for a story she's accompanied by a
photographer who turns out to be a CIA
spook and is quickly put to death by the
warlord she's interviewing according to
remarks later made during his press tour
for the film that's actually Jimmy Olsen
although Snyder didn't think there was
any rum in the DC Cinematic Universe for
him the director decided putting one of
Superman's best friends to the groupie
and filling him off would be a way to
have fun with the character
Zod of Candor we saw a return from man
of Steel's bad guy General Zod albeit in
the form of a corpse and then a CGI
monster while the trailer showed that to
be the case months before the move
dropped the little robots inside the
Kryptonian ship did give us another cool
little Easter egg we find out that Zod
comes from the city of kandor which is
better known to Comic fans as the bottle
city of Candor the capital city of
Krypton Candor is shrunken and stolen by
the superman villain Brainiac and is
added to his Intergalactic collection of
artifacts after Superman and Brainiac
Square Off Candor ends up under
Superman's protection at The Fortress of
Solitude hopefully we get a chance to
see a movie version of the classic
Superman villain with Pandora in toe The
Dark Knight Returns if you've watched
Watchmen you know that Zack Snyder likes
recreating comic panels in his film
adaptation and Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice is loaded with callbacks to
one of his biggest Inspirations the
Frank Miller graphic novel The Dark
Knight Returns it starts early with the
movie's depiction of Bruce Wayne's
Terence B kill a shot of Miss Wayne's
pearls around the mugger's gun is a
direct lift from the book and continues
throughout the movie both in the
dialogue and in the way certain shots
are lined up more than anything however
Batman's coward armor which he wears
during the title fight with Superman is
taken straight from Miller's iconic
series
Action Comics love him or hate him
Snyder definitely enjoys paying homage
to the comics one brief example comes
during an argument between Clark Kent
and Perry white at the office of the
Daily Planet during which white tells
Kent that he can't report on the types
of stories he wants to cover because
it's not 1938 anymore as any DC fan can
tell you that's the year Superman made
his first appearance in Action Comics
number one
must there be a Superman the movie's
Action Comics reference is far from the
only not the man of Steel's printed
adventures during one scene the senator
played by Holly Hunter asks must there
be a Superman it's an interesting
question and one that directly points to
a 1972 issue of the Superman comic in
which our hero is forced to face a
Tribunal for his quote crimes against
humanity since the hero is instrumental
in the defeat of Doomsday and the
foundation of the Justice League this is
a question that gets answered with a
resounding yes by the end of the movie
if you want to play a costume superhero
then you need to look the part and that
means intense workouts coupled with an
insane diet let's take a look at how
Zachary Levi went from Super Geek to
superhero and got ripped for Shazam
when Zachary Levi agreed to take on
Shazam as his next big role he
essentially agreed to make the gym his
second home after all this is a
character who has stood his ground in a
number of scraps with Superman over the
years if this confrontation is ever
going to play out on the big screen then
Levi has to at least keep Pace with
Henry Cavill assuming Cavill is still
playing the Man of Steel by the time a
crossover is viable the movie's official
synopsis even described Shazam as having
a ripped god-like body so there's Little
Wonder Levi began hitting the weights
almost every day during a chat with
former Smallville Lex Luthor actor
Michael Rosenbaum Levi said he's working
out five or six days a week he
elaborated like sometimes we'll do two a
days and then we'll get more off days
but typically we'll just go you know
hour and 15 minute sessions every day
that's a lot of time in the gym no
matter who you are and all that time
Pumping Iron definitely shows
when someone who doesn't work out
regularly starts hitting the gym hard
they usually experience what's known as
newbie gains yes you too can have a body
like mine if you're not careful
this was evidently the case for Levi who
managed to pack on an impressive amount
of pounds within his first six weeks of
training he told Rosenbaum in February
2018. before I got the roll I was about
200 pounds I hovered around 200 pounds
most of my dollar Levi gave a similar
account of his early gains when variety
caught up with him almost a year down
the line speaking to the Hollywood trade
at the New York City premiere of The
Marvelous Mrs maisel season two the
actor revealed that he'd started seeing
results right away I immediately put on
about 24 pounds and then we carved that
down in about half so I've been hovering
around 215 pounds and I'm in the best
shape of my life and stronger and
happier and healthier than I've ever
been what's going on oh well I I got
into really good shape am I hitting the
light right
what's happening why why
it probably won't surprise you to learn
that Levi had to consume a heroic amount
of calories to achieve a Shazam worthy
physique when variety quizzed him about
his weight gain at The Marvelous Mrs
maisel season 2 premiere the actor
revealed that he'd been taking on
between three thousand and four thousand
calories a day ever since he won the
lead role in the DC movie I mean just
walk down this peanut brittle real quick
why would you do that
all right because calories Levi went on
to give a more detailed breakdown of his
Shazam calorie count during his
appearance on Michael rosenbaum's
podcast 3 700 calories then like a bunch
of other supplements like fish oil
omega-3 it's an impressive amount of
calories for sure but how does it match
up against Levi's DC counterparts the
short answer is that well it doesn't
both Ben Affleck and Henry Cavill
reportedly consumed up to 5 000 calories
per day when training to play Batman and
Superman
Levi described his diet as pretty lean
and clean and he really wasn't kidding
to achieve his body goals the actor had
to give up some of his favorite snacks
and make every single mouthful count
which is why most of his meals consist
of protein-rich chicken and large
portions of broccoli a favorite of
bodybuilders everywhere Levi was even
eating broccoli for breakfast at one
stage documenting The Experience on
Instagram stories one bemused follower
took to Twitter to ask the actor why he
would do such a thing and Levi revealed
that he has a variation on chicken and
broccoli five times a day I basically
eat the same macros all day long meat
and veg vary in combinations I used to
eat a lot of eggs in the morning but I
think I have an intolerance to them
hopefully that means he didn't have to
down any raw egg shakes Rocky Style
Levi's physical transformation has
clearly been a source of inspiration to
his fans with some even reaching out to
ask the actor for hints and tips on
getting jacked he told one of his
followers it's a marathon not a Sprint
I've been in the gym five days a week
for the last five months and I've eaten
pretty darn healthy strictly but not so
crazy that I'm not still enjoying life
the system works when another fan asked
how her skinny husband could look more
like Levi the actor revealed that he
himself used to struggle with adding
muscle to a slender frame and it was all
down to diet according to Levi you can
work out constantly but if you aren't
providing your body with all the right
tools then you're going to struggle to
improve on those newbie gains the former
Chuck star replied the key I found was
quite literally consuming mass
quantities you have to feed your muscles
you have to give your body the building
material necessary to grow larger you
have to eat even when you're not hungry
fourteen thousand calories later I found
myself down at Subway
powering through a 12 inch veggie on
mole wheat
Levi might Advocate eating as much as
humanly possible but that doesn't mean
eating whatever you can get your hands
on when he was asked how he manages to
eat well while still enjoying his life
he gave a pretty straightforward answer
avoid processed foods from my
perspective the biggest favor you can do
for yourself is avoiding all processed
foods sweet or savory doesn't matter
it's all breaking down and your body is
sugar that is then stored as fat but
there's a lot of tasty clean food out
there get into it
why are you eating stem first this is a
new food for me how well should I eat it
the other way
junk food is far from the only obstacle
when you're trying to balance gem life
with the social life however alcohol
certainly doesn't help matters when
you're trying to remain as trim as
possible I'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please
Levi discovered the benefits of cutting
out the booze when he took part in sober
October 2018. star admitted it was a
little difficult at first and it's still
kind of strange not having a drink when
I go out at night but overall I feel so
much healthier and happier and clearer
of mind and heart it's been a good
cleanse may even take it longer we'll
see
finding the time to prepare five clean
meals a day can be a big challenge for
anybody let alone a busy actor but
that's where having a major Hollywood
studio as your boss comes in handy Levi
praised Warner Brothers for helping him
reach his targets when he spoke to
Michael Rosenbaum revealing that the
studio had arranged for his meals to be
brought right to his door he said yeah I
do meal delivery it's part of the job
and I and they've been and they've been
very awesome about taking care of them
that's all well and good but what does
Levi do when he's not home as an actor
he has to travel a lot but even then he
sticks to his regimented diet plan he
tweeted I use different meal delivery
companies in different cities because I
need to eat a lot throughout the day and
I don't know how to cook like at all
imagine putting yourself through months
of training and hundreds of portions of
broccoli only for one of the biggest
names and fitness to call you a fraud
that's the situation Levi found himself
in during March 2018 when Men's Health
suggested that the actor was wearing a
padded suit on set some behind the
scenes photos of Levi in full costume
were leaked online and regular
contributor viddy Mancuso took one look
at the size of Levi's biceps and called
Foul Play in response to the Men's
Health investigation Levi posted a
picture of his bicep on Twitter along
with the caption so much padding it was
the actor's way of getting back at the
fitness bag but the author of the
original article wasn't convinced in
fact Vinnie Mancuso said the photo Levi
posted was actually evidence that he was
correct about the suit padding all along
in a follow-up article he said yes that
is a large arm that is a gym earned
above average size appendage but try to
tell yourself honestly that the arm in
that photo is the same arm in the leaked
photo you can't you just can't do it
Levi's had a hard time shaking the fake
muscle rumors since his spat with Men's
Health some people seem to think he
looked padded out in a trailer that
dropped in January 2019 with one fan
questioning just how he looked so huge
the actor gave a purposefully
non-committal answer that's likely
because he's sick of addressing the
story by now when variety asked him
about it on the red carpet just a few
weeks earlier Levi again denied that he
needed extra mass especially in this
area does that look like fake does that
look fake to you come on
according to a study by the Society of
Behavioral Medicine having a workout
partner can greatly improve your
performance in the gym doubling cardio
results in some instances while many
superhero actors are set up with
world-renowned trainers the guy spotting
Levi is actually a photographer by trade
Eric Blackman has posted multiple pics
and videos of Levi Pumping Iron
unofficially documenting the actor's
progress in October 2017 Blackman
tweeted apparently I'll be getting
ripped for Shazam as well since Zachary
Levi is kicking my ass in the gym I need
protein now despite the Bleak winter
weather the pair remained dedicated to
the Shazam cause as 2018 rolled around
by February Levi was already looking far
more heroic in their sessions and by May
both men were looking fighting fit
Levi replied to the second men's health
article with another photo of his guns
and this one was harder to argue against
the actor posted a topless pic of
himself in the gym along with a
hilarious equation it's like the old
saying goes hard work overtime plus
chicken and broccoli minus carbs divided
by whey protein in which X represents
the amount of supplements and Y
represents the sentiment of why the hell
am I doing this to myself multiplied by
Shameless selfies whilst staring into
nowhere talk about taking your workouts
to the next level why is this so hard to
understand this is not
string theory
when he spoke to Variety in December
2018 Levi was eager to discuss how being
selected to play the lead role in Shazam
changed his life in more ways than one
his name is now known across the board
in Hollywood and he likely picked up a
pretty paycheck for his work on the
shazam movie but he was also extremely
grateful for the chance to get healthy
honestly that's the stuff that I'm most
ecstatic about just the level of Health
that I've gotten to mental health
emotional health spiritual health
physical health I am so jazzed about
that and I want to keep talking about
that particularly mental health it would
have been easy for Levi to give up after
Men's Health suggested that he just
wasn't big enough to play a superhero
but he wasn't working out for anyone but
himself he added I just feel like we're
in a place particularly nowadays where
people need to be encouraged and
informed on what self-love is and to go
and genuinely Embrace themselves and
love themselves so I'm really happy
about all of that sorry
ah I just had to reboot
Justice League didn't hold back in any
of the big moments we had a
planet-threatening disaster a team of
superheroes determined to stop it and a
good old-fashioned race between Superman
and Flash now that justice has been
served on the big screen we're doing
Justice to the little moments and small
details you may have missed in Justice
League spoilers ahead
crisis Cameo early in the film you may
have caught that newspaper headline for
the Metropolis post asking if a bunch of
fallen heroes returned to their own
planets what you may not have noticed
was the smaller headline beside the main
story city-wide crisis in the DC
Universe a crisis is kind of a big deal
and DC doesn't throw the c word around
casually it started in Justice League of
America number 21 with the crisis on
Earth 1 storyline in the very next issue
there was crisis on Earth 2 later 1985's
game-changing crisis on infinite Earth's
story arc put the entire Multiverse in
Peril various crises even popped up
after that like Infinite Crisis identity
crisis and final crisis basically most
of DC Comics history has been defined by
crises so name dropping the word in a
dceu movie is definitely a piece of fan
service
smooth finish for the majority of the
movie cyborg had a notably different
look than he does in the comics most
versions of cyborg in the comics have a
smooth aerodynamic exterior in Justice
League however cyborg had sharp edges
sticking out everywhere like a sentient
pile of Cutlery but at the end of
Justice League Vic uses his growing
control over the motherbox tech to give
himself a makeover ditching the RoboCop
2 Vibe for a polished shell lifted
straight from the comics and while we're
on the topic of cyborg booyah
throughout Cyborg's run on Teen Titans
and Teen Titans Go Sparky has had one
distinguishing catchphrase just
practicing my booyahs
it takes most of Justice League to get
there but right at the end he drops his
big line giving at least some of the
audience a reason to get out of their
seats with a smile
if you've never come across cyborg in
any form before Justice League you'd
never know what all the fuss was about
oh yeah
yeah Mira Amber heard's character Mira
didn't get a ton of screen time in
Justice League but the costume designers
definitely paid homage to Mira's comic's
Wardrobe from a crown to her green
Scaled Armor the likeness is exact
unfortunately Justice League left the
fate of Mira and the nature of a
relationship with Aquaman up in the air
but since Amber Heard is slated to star
in the upcoming Aquaman film it looks
like we'll get to see what finally
happens with the future queen of
Atlantis
Red Sky of Doom leading up to the climax
of Justice League Steppenwolf takes the
mother boxes back to that little Russian
town to start his apocalypse
terraforming picnic the sky turned blood
red on the surface that red sky is pure
apocalypse Steppenwolf turning Earth
into a version of his reddish world
after all but under the surface that red
sky represents very dc-specific levels
of Doom leading up to and during the
crisis on infinite Earth's storyline DC
Comic artists started coloring the skies
red in their other comic books most of
the time that was the only tie-in which
is the reason panels like this showed up
in comics like Swamp Thing so while
those red skies made sense in the movie
they also represented DC's classic way
of saying big things are going down
gorilla sign language if you could give
the flash an iconic Nemesis that wasn't
another Speedster it would undoubtedly
be Gorilla Grodd a hyper-intelligent ape
who's got a hyper personal Vendetta
against the flash obviously there
weren't any giant gorillas in Justice
League but there was a mention of that
classic villain albeit briefly when
Bruce Wayne tracks down Alan the super
Speedster tries to convince Wayne that
he's not really the flash which leads to
this line fluent in Sign Language
Guerrilla sign language for fans of the
comics it was immediately obvious that
Alan was referring to Grodd the greatest
gorilla in the DC Universe at least
outside of Jacob Apes the Joker's
adopted gorilla's son but this was much
more likely A sly reference to Grodd
cold resistance
in that same scene where Bruce Wayne
first meets Barry Allen there are a ton
of things going on in the background if
you weren't paying attention to the Rick
and Morty episode you might have noticed
something else on one of those screens
look closely at the monitor directly
behind and to the left of Ezra Miller
and pay attention to the words at the
top cold resistance clearly Barry has
been testing his suits tolerance for a
chill and one particular flash villain
comes to mind when you think of cold
Captain Cold AKA Leonard snart one of
Flash's deadliest villains
does this mean that flash has already
defeated Captain cold in this universe
or was he gearing up for a confrontation
when Steppenwolf uh stepped on
everyone's plans we just don't know
ace chemicals they're a good handful of
Easter eggs emblazoned on the buildings
throughout the film one of which was a
small neon sign advertising ace
chemicals and if you know your comic's
history you know where this is going
yup ace chemicals is the chemical plant
where the Joker fell into a toxic vat
and became well the Joker it's gone by
different names and different versions
of the origin story it was called access
chemicals in 1989's Batman and oddly
Monarch claim card company in the
original run of Detective Comics but ace
chemicals is now DC Cannon for the name
of the birthplace of the Joker in
Justice League this sign is a blink and
you'll miss a detail but it's a nice
touch on the World building of the movie
Gotham gargoyle nothing says Batman like
standing on a gargoyle high above Gotham
on a dark stormy night
if you could put that image in a bottle
it'd smell like the inside of Batman's
cowl guaranteed so the shot of Batman on
a grim reaper gargoyle in the Justice
League Comic-Con trailer was a definite
crowd pleaser
if you've done your homework and read
all gazillion issues of Detective Comics
you might recognize that Reaper image
the shot is a direct homage to the cover
of Detective Comics Number 682
Ancient King after steppenwolf's first
invasion of Earth the three mother boxes
were split among the races the
atlanteans and Amazons built cool little
shrines for their boxes but the men
being men decided they couldn't trust
anyone so they buried theirs out in the
woods
IMDb only lists the main guy there as
the Ancient King of men there's one
particular Ancient King of men who
definitely plays a role in the DC
Universe King Arthur most of the
mythological lore of King Arthur is kept
intact in the DCU so it's definitely
possible that he was the one who would
be entrusted with the mother box after a
war that happened hundreds of years ago
super plaid Superman is the worst at
disguises but that's part of who he is
so we're all okay with that by now then
somewhere along the line live-action
adaptations of Superman decided that he
also needed to add plaid to his
repertoire of implausibly common
wardrobe choices maybe it's because he
grew up on a farm in Kansas and that's
what Farmers wear whatever the reason
old Clark's been putting on plaid
whenever he visits the Family Farm ever
since 1978 Superman it's usually red but
not always it was white in Superman 4
and white again in Superman Returns Man
of Steel got nervous and put his mom in
plaid but oh there's Clark wearing plaid
again in Batman vs Superman all the way
in Metropolis too
some of his shirts have some of the
Plaid in them so there's a little
reminder of the the midwestern boy from
Kansas and who can forget the CW
Smallville a show that spent more on
plaid than sister act's entire budget
for nun costumes which brings us back to
Justice League where Clark heads out to
the farm in Smallville to talk to Lois
in plaid even though she totally knows
who he is and he can just wear the suit
with a big ass she just called him Clark
in front of a dozen policemen while he
was supermaning the Super Friends so why
did he change to Plaid because it's an
Easter egg look the bottom line is if
you ever see a guy anywhere wearing
plaid there's a 30 chance it's Superman
task force x did its job and the world
is safe for now Suicide Squad may be a
critical punching bag but it still has
its rewards for comic book die hards
including a bunch of references and
homages for the faithful to enjoy so
let's pick up Harley Quinn's Mallet and
start smashing some Suicide Squad Easter
eggs watching The Watchmen remember when
Deadshot looks into the clothing store
window and starts moping out about his
daughter that huge yellow smiley face
behind the mannequins wasn't there by
chance in DC Comics 2016 rebirth event
the world of the Watchmen officially
entered the DC Universe and it may only
be a matter of time before that happens
in the movies as well with this and
similar Easter eggs like the Watchmen
graffiti in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice helping to set up the inevitable
Frosty flunky while the Joker mostly
employs nameless goons one of his men
Sports a name tag reading Mr Frost Brian
azarella's graphic novel Joker was told
from the perspective of Johnny Frost who
goes from being Joker's chauffeur to
become his top man the scenes of Harley
shaking her stuff in a nightclub and Mr
Frost being the joker's number one guy
are likely both inspired by azarella's
story high rise tribute This Blink and
you'll miss it Easter egg is pretty easy
to figure out if you know your DC
history the giant building the team
infiltrates to rescue Amanda Waller is
named after Comics writer John Ostrander
while Ostrander didn't create the
original team that debuted in 1959 he
did come up with a modern Suicide Squad
in 1987. what goes around comes around
when Captain Boomerang convinced the
Slipknot his neck bomb is a dud the
scene mirrors what happens in the comics
after Boomerang tells Slipknot that
their wrist mounted bombs were fake of
course in the comics the bomb only blew
off his arm instead of his head well you
win some you lose some dancing with the
devil in the pale Moonlight some people
might prefer Harley Quinn's classic
black and red costume but at least her
original outfit appears in the movie
when the squad premares to go to Midway
City Harley pulls out a familiar looking
outfit but tosses it aside in favor of
something a bit more revealing for bad
guys it's what we do we also got to see
Margot Robbie down the classic Harley
get up in a flashback sequence which
recreates artist Alex Ross's iconic
cover to 1999's Batman Harley Quinn time
away from Mr J after being let down by
the Joker a few times throughout the
movie Harley appears to have some second
thoughts about her maniacal boyfriend
huh her budding friendship and
flirtatious chemistry with Will Smith's
dead shot is a call back to what happens
in the comics and the animated feature
Batman assault and Arkham where things
occasionally got hot heavy and downright
weird between these two Batman villains
it didn't itch thought you could help me
scratch Cowboy
flash back
this Easter egg is kind of obvious but
it's still pretty awesome Captain
boomerang's introductory flashback
sequence shows a jewelry store robbery
in which his getaway is stopped by Ezra
Miller's flash it's only right that
Captain Boomerang is thwarted by the
scar that speedster since he first
appeared as a flash villain way back in
1960 in an interview with collider
director David Ayer revealed that this
scene was shot while Suicide Squad was
in post-production this scene was
directed by Batman vs Superman director
Zack Snyder while he was filming Justice
League
critics and audiences agree that Aquaman
feels like a breath of fresh air after
drowning in DC's Mercury efforts it's a
light funny Adventure film anchored by
two Charming leads and buoyed by
eye-popping visuals but a vessel this
large can only turn its Rudder so fast
and it's bound to have a few Barnacles
still clinging to its Hull prepare for
spoilers and continue Full Speed Ahead
to the three best and three worst things
about Aquaman
Batman and Superman have some pretty
iconic bad guys always giving them grief
by contrast Aquaman doesn't the movie
introduces perhaps the two most
significant villains from the pages of
Aquaman Comics Black Manta and Ocean
Master both of them are okay but the
story suffers slightly from having two
separate antagonists diluting the story
central conflict it's a problem all too
common to superhero movies at least we
know we'll get more of Black Manta and
that big laser shooting helmet of his in
the inevitable sequel Jason Momoa was a
highlight of Justice League and fans
have been looking forward to more of his
likable Dirtbag embodiment of Arthur
Curry not only does the Aquaman Solo
movie live up to its potential as a
Momoa vehicle it supports him with one
of the best Cass yet assembles for the
dceu it's an Eclectic Ensemble with some
surprising cameos but each gets a moment
to shine and unlike some of the more
convoluted comic movies in recent memory
everyone's clearly on the same page
about what kind of strange Adventure
they're on Momoa continues his shtick as
the buff waterlogged Barfly with the
Heart of Gold but being the center of
attention allow allows them to add new
layers to the character he lets Arthur
self-doubt bubble to the surface in his
most vulnerable moments making him
endearing without sacrificing any of his
Rowdy charm meanwhile Amber Heard
successfully leads alongside him as
Meera with a perfect balance of fearsome
focus and wide-eyed Wonder from her
scene wandering Sicily with Arthur to
her battle through the city heard makes
Mira a true standout Justice League
formally introduced audiences to Aquaman
but only had time for a brief
exploration of his Atlantean Origins
Mira appeared in one sequence in which
Arthur attempted to protect a mother box
from Steppenwolf Arthur expressed
bitterness over being abandoned by his
mother Queen Atlanta and held her
neglect against the people of Atlantis
the Arthur we catch up with in Aquaman
is less angry at his mother he's aware
that she was forced to return to the Sea
and learns that she was sacrificed to a
monster-filled place called the trench
for the crime of having a half-breed son
filling him with grief and guilt the
movie more or less has to undo the
motivations established in Justice
League in order to get his character Arc
moving in the right direction there's
also a change how atlanteans communicate
it seemed Injustice League that Arthur
and Meera could only talk inside an air
bubble but Aquaman has its characters
speak freely even when submerged it
makes sense that a movie set mostly
underwater would choose not to
complicate its character's ability to
talk to each other in this way but it
raises the question of why Justice
League introduced such a clunky conceit
in the first place
fans might be slightly annoyed at
Aquaman's contradictions of established
dceu lore but this actually becomes one
of its strongest assets the movie is
completely unburdened by connections to
other movies either past or present
where Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
nearly drowned in setups and
introductions designed to pay off in
future installments Aquaman floats free
unencumbered by the sort of
franchise-minded filmmaking that has
sunk other comic book movies aside from
briefly mentioning Arthur's battle with
Steppenwolf Aquaman contains no
reference to any other DC characters not
involved in its hero's journey no secret
Lex Corp files no foreshadowing of
cataclysmic events to come it's just a
straight ahead adventure story about
Aquaman and his friends and enemies it
is in fact a perfect jumping on point
for newcomers to the DC Universe
something Warner Brothers sorely needs
after the convoluted webs of its
predecessors proved off-putting for
audiences and critics
regardless of how well Aquaman plays to
its strengths it's still going to be the
story of a would-be king who talks to
fish and does battle with mer people it
will probably never reach the universal
Acclaim of something like The Dark
Knight a movie based on comic books and
treated as a hard-hitting police drama
Arthur Curry's Adventures will simply
never have the same potential for
crossover appeal
but here's the thing about a movie that
leans all the way into its own comic
book silliness it's exactly what DC
films needs right now while some
Discerning theater goers might be turned
off by such a goofy outing as Aquaman it
serves as the perfect antidote to the
Grim self-seriousness of movies like
Batman vs Superman tell me
do you played we've watched Superman die
and we've seen Batman live long enough
to become the villain even wonder woman
solo story didn't have much time for
levity once Diana arrived in the
trenches of World War One Justice League
had a jarring tonal dissonance trapped
somewhere between brooding and romping
see your Genius move is dying
you really are out of your mind
but Aquaman is bright wacky and seems
intent on doing nothing Beyond shooting
fun straight into viewers eyeballs
Arthur's tale is a feel-good story
concerned not with societal ethics or
the meaning of existence but with his
own journey to find his own place and
commit to what he cares about it will
never make a short list of important
films or warrant major Oscar
consideration but it isn't trying to
it's just fun and in a year when Marvel
slaughtered half of all life in the
universe that makes it a welcome dash of
lightness and joy
show off
I could have just peed on it
Wonder Woman 1984 is a treat for all
ages but there are many aspects of it
that only adult viewers grasp from the
film's most obscure references to its
uncomfortable moments these are all the
things only adults notice in Wonder
Woman 1984.
as the title implies Wonder Woman 1984
picks up with Diana in the midst of one
of Hollywood's favorite decades to
portray the 1980s there's a lot to love
about the 80s from the decades awesome
music to its gleaming video stores and
anyone who lived through the 1980s will
recognize many real details from that
time scattered throughout the set of
Wonder Woman 1984 sparked by The
public's obsession with Fitness people
everywhere were donning Spandex and leg
warmers in its earliest shots of people
on the street of DC Wonder Woman 1984
offers a number of examples of this look
speaking of fashion no 80s setting would
be complete with ridiculously
over-the-top parachute pants and a whole
lot of metallic fabric Steve Travis
shows off a few of these looks when he
and Diana attempt to find him an era
appropriate look even the crosswalk
signs in Wonder Woman 1984 are accurate
to the time period before today's modern
LEDs were installed in the early 2000s a
signage did indeed display the words
Walk Don't Walk rather and the current
symbols representing a person in
mid-stride
Wonder Woman 1984 gets a whole lot right
about the 1980s but there is still one
important plot detail that it manages to
get majorly wrong this error can be
spotted at the beginning of maxlord's
big finale speech after successfully
taking over the world's broadcasting
signals using secret government Tech
Lord is able to Splash his face across
the screens of unwitting bystanders
everywhere no matter where Diana turns
his face is visible urging the people of
the world to wish for what they want and
see their wildest dreams come true the
only problem with this super villainous
scheme is that those screens
broadcasting Lord's face include
television and computer displays this
scene takes place decades before the
internet or streaming services became
publicly available in fact the concept
of a home computer was considered
incredibly novel and exotic at the time
as Apple had just started selling their
first generation of Macintosh computers
that January this sort of
all-encompassing broadcast wasn't just
impossible at the time it was basically
Unthinkable this is a highly
sophisticated office computer now this
blooper wasn't caught by the production
team prior to release it just goes to
show how easy it is to take technology
for granted
adults can't help but roll their eyes on
one of Max Law's last business investors
Simon Stagg threatens to report him to
the Federal Trade Commission if Max
doesn't return his investment money
within 48 hours this sort of race
against the clock Trope is favored by
film and television producers because it
provides a sense of urgency to the plot
without being too restrictive the
48-hour timeline is a particularly
popular choice we have 48 hours starting
on my mark you have 48 hours to get my
money in 48 hours we have 20 seconds
you have 48 Hours the 1982 action comedy
movie 48 Hours starring Nick Nolte and
Eddie Murphy literally calls itself out
for using this cliche in its very title
we can't blame the filmmakers for using
this reliable plot point but it does get
repetitive younger viewers may find Max
Lord's conflict engaging but more mature
audiences might find it to be more than
a little bit predictable the technology
Max Lord uses to take over the planet's
Airwaves in Wonder Woman 1984 maybe the
surf of Science Fiction but the parent
program mentioned in the movie as its
comparison was actually entirely real
the 1980s marked the height of the Cold
War when the United States and the
Soviet Union were attempting to one-up
each other while maintaining a public
pretense of Peace secret government
programs proliferated during this era
one of which was known as a Strategic
Defense Initiative or SDI a missile
defense system proposed by Ronald Reagan
in 1983 as an attempt to render nuclear
weapons obsolete nicknames the Star Wars
program the SDA proposed to utilize
state-of-the-art technology and weapons
like lasers satellites and ground and
space-based missile systems to
neutralize incoming threats like nuclear
missiles it was officially scrapped in
1993.
Kristen Wiig does an excellent job
portraying the painfully shy and awkward
character of Barbara Minerva who
transforms from an introverted
Wallflower into the empowered apex
predator known as cheetah however
Barbara's character Arc might seem
remarkably familiar to older audience
members who have seen more movies that's
because Barbara's story revolves on the
access of a heavily played out Trope the
one where the disregarded nerdy girl
gets a makeover and suddenly transforms
into a popular hottie just look at my
fair lady Greece The Princess Diaries
and she's all that indeed this plot
Point has been seen countless times
before and is use tends to marginalize
the character in question far more than
it empowers them so put it plainly no
one is surprised to see The Ugly
Duckling become the swan any longer
especially because the duckling is
pretty much always already attractive
okay now take your glasses off let that
hair down and act like you don't know
how pretty you are
and Wonder Woman 1984 Diana and
wittingly uses a cover to dreamstone to
bring her Lost Love Steve Trevor back
from the dead but he doesn't return in
the way he'd expect rather than
magically resurrecting his body the
dreamstone inserts Steve Trevor's
Consciousness into the body of another
man living near Diana in Washington DC
to minimize audience confusion the
handsome man as he's credited is shown
briefly at the start of his possession
then his likeness switches to Steve
Travis it's possible this was intended
as some sort of metaphor about only
having eyes for your true love if
there's something younger audiences
might be able to buy into a little more
easily but this magical body snatching
comes off as more problematic than
romantic for adults Steve Trevor doesn't
know who handsome man is and disrupts
his entire life with his presence what
happens to his job his social life and
all other aspects of his existence when
he suddenly becomes Steve wouldn't the
poor man be terrified when suddenly
coming to after Steve Rogers forfeits
his parasitic existence also one can't
help but wonder what the implications
are of being intimate with someone's
body when they have no presence of mind
to provide consent at the very least
it's unnerving
Wonder Woman 1984 is a superhero movie
so there are always going to be some
weird physics involved these people are
superheroes after all can Diana lasso
lightning sure why not but the film is
also loaded with unrealistic depictions
of physics and technology that are hard
to ignore especially for a jaded adult
for example when Steve insists on flying
a modern plane he does so without tissue
despite the massive differences between
planes he flew during World War One and
the modern jet here and Diana commandeer
the way I fly they will never find us
and when Diana manages to make the jet
magically invisible it also
simultaneously disappears from radar but
just because an object becomes invisible
to the naked eye doesn't mean it also
becomes invisible to radar because the
mass of the plane is still there to
reflect the radar waves then again she
made the plane invisible so we can't
nitpick this one too much maybe it's all
part of her invisibility magic but
there's also the fact that at high
altitude it gets pretty hard to breathe
without oxygen that's a little harder to
explain away for human man Steve
I can't breathe but Diana and Steve chat
away and assisted as though they're
toddling down the highway rather than
speeding through the air thousands of
feet about hundreds of miles an hour
likewise the final battle between Wonder
Woman and cheetah defies the rules of
electricity to the point of silliness
the two women are impervious to
thousands of volts of electricity in
ways that can only be explained with
comic book logic and again this is a
comic book movie so that's fair game
then suddenly those excuses stop
mattering at all when the Live Wire
cheetah swings from without any apparent
trouble contacts towards her she's
immersed in and becomes a source of her
defeat professional wrestling is beloved
by people of all ages but younger fans
likely miss the real-life reference
planted in the midst of Wonder Woman
1984. while visiting the home of a man
with important information regarding the
dreamstone Diana examines a magazine
lying near his front door it's the
August 1984 issue of pro wrestling
Illustrated featuring Jerry The King
Lawler on the front cover as it turns
out this particular issue really does
exist and it really was in Prince at the
time this was excitedly pointed out by
Lawler himself on Twitter after Stuart
Shrek of DC Comics brought it to his
attention it might seem random to
feature a pro wrestling themed magazine
in Wonder Woman 1984 but at the Time
Sports entertainment had reached a
pinnacle of unparalleled popularity the
1980s were a huge decade for
professional wrestling in particular to
the point that it is often referred to
as a sports Golden Age offering a nod to
the suspect of the decade is something
many grown-up viewers have Wonder Woman
1984 no doubt appreciate
in the DC EU asterio is a celebrated
champion of the Amazons who selflessly
sacrificed herself in battle so the rest
of her sisters could flee to the safety
of what would become their mascara this
Fallen Hero was remembered as The Golden
Warrior for her courageous hearts and
legendary armor to honor Asteria a
golden statue of her likeness was
erected in the mysterious Coliseum the
Amazonian athletic competition shown in
the beginning of the film is also held
as a way to remember and reflect upon
asteria's Legacy in real life Asteria
was a name given to several prominent
figures in Greek mythology meaning
Starry one interestingly this particular
strand of Mythology portrays hysteria as
eventually transforming into an island
to escape Zeus's advances adult viewers
will pick up on how reminiscent this is
of her origin story regarding the island
of the mascara and how it echoes
yamazon's desires to separate themselves
from the world of men culture and
Technology may have changed but Tales of
heroes and villains remain timeless
considering she fell in battle and was
never heard from again the Amazons
naturally assumed that Asteria died
defending them this assumption was
reinforced when Diana went on a mission
to find the Fallen Warrior and was only
able to track down asteria's Golden
Eagle armor which he winds up using in
her final Face-Off against cheetah and
Max Lord however Wonder Woman 1984's
mid-credits scene reveals that Asteria
is very much alive secretly living among
no more humans and saving the occasional
baby when the opportunity presents
itself although younger viewers may not
recognize a stunning brunette playing
hysteria in the scene adults and
doubtedly Will Carter made a name for
herself playing Diana Prince on the
classic Wonder Woman television series
which originally aired on ABC and CBS
from 1975 to 1979 despite the fact that
she's been portraying Amazon Warriors
for quite some time Carter still manages
to Dazzle new viewers in 2020 and Beyond
just as she did all the way back in the
70s it will be interesting to see what
DC has plans for the ice iconic actress
hopefully there's more to come for her
new character Beyond this brief if
thrilling appearance
Zack Snyder's justice league isn't
ambitious four-hour epic packed with
tons of previously unseen footage as
well as contradictions and unexplained
moments here are those confusing moments
explained
of all the minor continuity
discrepancies between the DC EU movies
one of the most noticeable is the case
of Aquaman's eye color if you've missed
out on the weed and cut of Justice
League back in 2017 then you may be used
to the brown yellows closer to Jason
momoa's natural eye color in James
Juan's Aquaman in the 2017 Justice
League Aquaman can be seen with striking
baby blues this coloring was brought
back again in the Snyder cut leaving
some viewers reasonably confused as it
turns out this is a choice both
directors are very aware of and cite as
an artistic difference but according to
Momoa it was a decision motivated by
something the actor himself said in an
interview with the Huffington Post
promoting Aquaman back in 2018 Memorial
revealed about the change
it was my idea I brought to Zach I
thought it would be rad to have a
different eye color something that's
completely Atlantean that was like his
Mark I felt like it was just something
that would be a little otherworldly so
Zach really liked it as for why director
James Wan went in a different direction
Momoa said I feel like Juan wanted to
have a warmer thing in this movie I feel
like my justification for the change is
that he kind of went home he's more
rooted and he's calm when he's around
his family
another inconsistency between Aquaman
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice and
Zack Snyder's Justice League has no real
bearing on their overall plots but is a
detail that can be irksome to anyone
following the DCU releases thus far it's
time to talk about the Trident in Zack
Snyder's Justice League Queen Atlanta's
Trident is presented to Aquaman by volco
volco encourages Aquaman to take the
Trident and claim his Birthright to the
throne of Atlantis he declines setting
up the 2018 Aquaman Arc in the
theatrical version of the film this was
replaced by a scene between Mira and
Aquaman after Steppenwolf steals the
Mother Box hidden in Atlantis it's
implied that Mira gives Aquaman the
Trident that he uses to fight in the
rest of the film in both cuts of the
film he uses the Trident during battle
with the parademons but the moment where
Aquaman seems to ask for the Trident
doesn't exist in the Snyder cut
however that still doesn't explain the
footage first shown in Snyder's previous
movie Batman vs Superman which shows
Aquaman with a trident that looks pretty
much exactly like the weapon he wields
in Justice League does Aquaman just have
an extra Trident that looks just like
his mother's
this is another perplexing moment that
is a result of creative changes made
following the lackluster theatrical
release of Justice League the way Snyder
envisioned underwater Communications
between atlanteans works just fine for
his movie but James 1 made some changes
to fit his vision for Aquaman in both
versions of Justice League all
underwater conversations between
atlanteans happen in air bubbles they
create in James Juan's Aquaman the
atlanteans no longer require these
bubbles to speak to each other
underwater why did this happen whenever
you notice something like that a wizard
did it well not really Juan said in an
Entertainment Weekly interview people
are overthinking it they're just gonna
talk honestly it's hard to imagine him
having any other stance Snyder's stylish
portrayal of Atlantean communication
would have quickly become annoying in a
movie that takes place primarily in
Atlantis
to many who grew up with the Justice
League comics and cartoons Green Lantern
is a core member of The League sadly the
Colossal bomb that was 2011's Green
Lantern movie with Ryan Reynolds ensured
that DC won't be touching Hal Jordan for
a good while but it seems like Snyder
has put the wheels in motion to one day
bring Green Lantern back into the Vault
the climax of the second part of Zack
Snyder's Justice League is a flashback
of Epic Proportions it depicts the first
Age of Heroes and the final battle
between Darkseid and the humans
atlanteans and Amazons the one Lantern
visible yalan Gore was in the original
cut but in the Snyder cut he explicitly
dies by darkseid's hand the scene also
highlights how the ring escaped and
continued the hero's line which
presumably would have been followed up
on in a future Justice League sequel
Yellen Gore wasn't the only lantern that
made an appearance in the Snyder cut
kilowog is set up to be one of the main
characters in HBO Max's Green Lantern
core series appears dead in Cyborg's
vision of the desolate future timeline
AKA The Nightmare one of the most
surprising and unusual changes made to
the Snyder cut comes from a character
who isn't in the movie for a terribly
long amount of screen time still it's
enough to notice how Snyder has made
Mira change her accent or at least it
seems that way the truth is probably
much simpler
in Aquaman and 2017's Justice League
heard voiced the Atlantean Queen with an
accent that sounded more or less like
her regular speaking voice my parents
fought in the wars
took me in what a saint you dare speak
of Queen Atlanta that way Zack Snyder's
Justice League has heard putting on a
British accent my parents died in the
water
she took me in
what a saint
you dare speak of Queen Atlanta that way
it's likely that the original scenes
with Mira for the movie were already
completely finished and were simply
added back for the Snyder cut this means
that the mirror scenes in 2017's Justice
League are almost certainly reshoots
this choice is minor and in keeping with
Snyder's objective to completely
preserve his original vision for the
film
if you are at all confused about the
scene with Lois Lane and a green space
alien impersonating Martha Kent don't
worry so are we later revealing himself
to Bruce Wayne and to the DC Universe At
Large Martian Manhunter AKA Jon Jones
makes his live-action debut in Zack
Snyder's Justice League in a mysterious
scene at the end of a long conversation
between Lois and Martha about Clark
Martha exits and unbeknownst to Lois
shapeshifts first into Martian Manhunter
and then into Secretary of Defense
Calvin swanwick in the scene Martha
advises Lois that she still needs to be
part of society which motivates her to
get out placing her in the right place
at the right time when Superman is
brought back to life this moment is
pivotal and the knowledge that Martian
Manhunter was orchestrating events in
the movie the whole time is mind-blowing
Martian Manhunter was one of the
original Justice League members and his
appearance of the Snyder verse brings
the League's new Total up to that oh so
important number seven now that we know
what Snyder planned for two Justice
League sequels we know he was going to
expand the group and bring in Green
Lantern and other DC Legends but now the
future of Martian Manhunter in the DCU
remains uncertain
a very important part of the Snyder
verse is the nightmare it's never really
explained in either Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice or Zack Snyder's Justice
League nor is it referred to by name
still understanding it is vital to
understanding the greater meaning behind
many of the new additions to the Snyder
cut the nightmare is introduced in
Batman vs Superman when Bruce dreams of
being in a Sandy washed out desert after
being ambushed by a group of men Batman
sees parademons coming in the distance
and is overtaken this Vision concludes
with the reveal of an evil Superman and
Bruce being awoken to a flash from the
future telling him Lois is the key it's
a reference to what happens in Justice
League but also is a clue to her
importance in the now shuttered sequel
Snyder was planning the nightmare itself
makes a return in the Snyder cut where
it becomes clear that Darkseid is the
cause of the apocalyptic future it's
never explicitly stated but Snyder has
explored Lane that this is a vision of
the future that must be stopped in the
Snyder cut we see Superman holding the
burned body of Lois in the bat cave
which is the turning point that Bruce
must never let happen
there's a lot to love about Zack
Snyder's Justice League but admittedly
it doesn't explain some of its biggest
Concepts such as what exactly is the
anti-life equation and why does Darkseid
want it so badly originally created for
DC's fourth world Arc in 1970 the
anti-life equation is a secret way of
controlling all sentient beings Darkseid
believes part of the equation exists in
the subconscious of humanity which is
why Steppenwolf interrogates people
using those creepy spider bugs
thematically a common interpretation is
that the equation is a mathematical
proof of the futility of living and a
way to dominate Humanity through
spreading hopelessness what it actually
is and whether or not it has a physical
form in the Snyder verse is one of the
biggest mysteries for the future of the
dceu it's not explained at all in the
movie but Superman's pitch black suit
has great historical significance that
references one of Snyder's key
Inspirations for his Justice League the
black suit in Zack Snyder's Justice
League is a reference to 1993's the
reign of Superman comic Arc the
follow-up to previous years The Death of
Superman which saw Superman die while
fighting doomsday when he comes back to
life in Rain he's wearing the black suit
in an iconic moment of DC Comics history
since then it has always been associated
with the death and Return of Superman in
the lore the suit was designed to help
the weakened Superman absorb more solar
energy so he can be stronger after
coming back to life while this may be
obvious to older DC Comics fans it's not
left unexplained for no reason there was
actually a deleted scene that was shot
during Snyder's original production that
showed a newly resurrected Superman
choosing to Don either a suit of
Kryptonian armor or the iconic black
suit
Joe Manganiello joined the DC universe's
Deathstroke in a mid-credit scene in the
theatrical cut of Justice League back in
2017. the yacht scene that served as his
introduction is in the Snyder cut but in
an altered form however the restored
version of the scene is more confusing
than anything else in the theatrical
Justice League Deathstroke's
introduction was a teaser for a Legion
of Doom movie where Luther gathers a
band of villains to face off against the
Justice League shouldn't we have a
league of Our Own
in the version of the scene that made it
into the Snyder cut Luther tells
Deathstroke Batman's true identity which
is a significant difference at the time
Snyder's intention was to make a
stand-alone Ben Affleck Batman film
following Justice League with
meganello's Deathstroke serving as the
main villain Affleck dropped out and the
Batman eventually turned into the Robert
Pattinson LED Matt Reeves directed
project currently in production now both
versions of Justice League have seen's
teasing movies that will never see the
light of day The Nightmare scene in the
epilogue is the most dire of all
parademons roam the land while Batman
and the rest of the league are at the
end of their rope Aquaman's deck
replaced by Mira Deathstroke is working
with the leak and Flash is wearing his
future costume from the Batman vs
Superman flashback
Jared Leto's Joker makes his return to
mock The Dark Knight one last time he
and Batman make important references to
the deaths of Robin Harley Quinn and
Lois Lane before Joker offers Bruce a
truce the sequence ends with the league
preparing for what might just be one
last battle at the end of the world with
Superman the scene is loaded with
implications about what might have
happened in the future of the Snyder
verse it confirms the death of Robin at
the hands of the Joker and that Bruce
letting Lois die in a tragic blast is
the turning point of the conflict
according to Snyder this tragedy allows
Superman to succumb to the anti-life
equation and therefore fall completely
under darkseid's control time travel and
multiverses were going to play a major
role in Justice League two and three but
now this single scene is the most we'll
see of Zack Snyder's dark Justice League
trilogy
from the lawsuit that took him out of
comics to his journey to being one of
the most highly anticipated Movie heroes
of this decade here's the Untold Truth
of Captain Mark Shazam after his debut
in 1938 Superman was a huge success so
successful in fact that he had inspired
a massive Boom for the brand new
superhero genre including a huge wave of
imitators and rip-offs dozens of new
titles hoped to create the next Superman
but faucet Publications was one
publisher that actually managed to do it
in 1940 writer Bill Parker and artist
CeCe Beck introduced the world to
Captain Marvel a character who had all
of Superman's powers but with two key
differences first Captain Marvel's
Origins were drawn from a more magical
mythological Source than the Sci-Fi
explanations behind Superman's power
second and far more importantly his
mild-mannered secret identity was a kid
Billy Batson a homeless child was chosen
by the wizard Shazam with a single magic
word he could transform into an adult
who wielded the powers of 6mm logical
Heroes turning him into the world's
Mightiest mortal
in other words every kid who wished they
were Superman could Now read The
Adventures of a kid who could become
Superman whenever he wanted with that
idea Captain Marvel was an instant
success if you got a good memory for
trivia you might already know that Billy
Batson and his magical Alter Ego made
their debuts in the very first issue of
whiz Comics but did you know that was
actually Wiz Comics number two that
might seem confusing but that's only
because it is before debuting a new
title Publishers would often create Ash
can editions cheap low quality versions
with low print runs that they could use
as proof of concept to attract potential
advertisers and secure a copyright
they'd done the same with Parker and
Beck's new character then called Captain
Thunder but still hadn't settled on a
title publishing it as both thrill
comics and Flash comics by the time they
got to publication they decided to go
with whiz since they'd already published
the story in The ashcan Whiz started at
number two even though they technically
printed it twice twice already Superman
might have been the original but as the
40s went on Captain Marvel quickly
became the most popular superhero of the
decade by outselling Superman in Action
Comics according to the Museum of comic
book advertising Captain Marvel
Adventures would eventually hit a high
point of 1.3 million sales per month
that's an impressive figure under any
circumstances but consider that over the
course of those same years Captain
Marvel and his Sidekicks were also
appearing in Wiz Comics wow Comics
Master Comics Captain Marvel Jr Mary
Marvel and the Marvel family in fact he
was so popular that hoppy the Marvel
bunny a rabbit version of Captain Marvel
created for Fawcett's line of funny
animal comics was headlining two titles
every month for comparison Superman and
Batman each had three and one of them
was world's finest Comics the series
they appeared in together if you ever go
back and read any Captain Marvel comics
from the 40s it's not difficult to
figure out the secret of their success
they're actually good while a lot of
golden age creators struggled with
figuring out the rules of the new medium
and the superhero genre the Captain
Marvel stories presented fun
straightforward and well-structured
Adventures CC Beck's art had always been
fantastic but the arrival of writer Otto
Bender was the final ingredient needed
to make Captain Marvel Great bender and
Beck would become the team that most
identified with the character and in
1943 they created what is generally
considered to be one of the most
important stories of the Golden Age The
Monster Society of evil the Society of
evil the vilest villains of Faucet City
United together we'll conquer the
universe it was an epic story that ran
through a full 25 issues of Captain
Marvel Adventures the first long-form
multi-part superhero story in comics it
was also the first story to feature a
villainous super team made up of
pre-existing villains who United to take
down the heroes Paving the way for the
modern day event comic as you might have
already guessed National Comics the
company that would later become DC was
not not happy about Captain Marvel
outselling Superman so unhappy in fact
that they filed a lawsuit against
Fawcett that made it to court in 1948
alleging that they'd violated the
copyright on Superman by ripping him off
for their own character unfortunately
for Fawcett that actually is what
happened thank you I wanted to be you
whenever I was out there facing down the
bad guys I think what would Superman do
now in a much later interview Roscoe
Fawcett would recall telling his staff
give me a Superman even beyond that the
similarities were impossible to ignore
Superman didn't have the market cornered
on super strength and invulnerability
but the cover to whiz Comics number two
featured Captain Marvel tossing a car
much like Superman on the cover of
Action Comics number one in 1954 the
courts ruled against Fawcett and they
lost the rights to continue publishing
Captain Marvel stories
after the infamous lawsuit Captain
Marvel's Adventures ended and while he
wouldn't be seen on the comics page
again for almost two decades a character
that was selling over a million copies a
month doesn't just vanish from pop
culture plenty of readers had fond
memories of the character and plenty of
Publishers were eager to recreate that
level of success in the United Kingdom a
publisher called l Miller and Son
drafted artist Mick Anglo to create an
unofficial continuation of the series
The Character was renamed Marvel man and
the magic word was changed to Kim Mota
since the British printings of Captain
Marvel had ended at number 24 Marvel man
picked up at number 25. it ran from 1954
to 1963 but in 1982 the strip was
revived in the pages of warrior it was
rebooted in a much darker Direction by
Alan Moore and Gary Leach and served to
pave the way for later more projects
like Watchmen in 1972 DC publisher
Carmine Infantino decided that Captain
Marvel had been absent long enough
with that DC licensed the characters
from Fawcett and began publishing all
new adventures of the original Captain
Marvel in the pages of Shazam the first
issue was drawn by CC Beck and featured
Otto Bender Who had left DC in 1969 to
focus on sci-fi novels as a character in
the first issue the series would run for
35 issues bringing the Marvel family to
a new generation of readers and
incorporating them into the DC
Multiverse readers weren't just
reintroduced to the good guys though in
Shazam number 28 Black Adam returned an
evil version of Captain Marvel who had
made his only appearance 32 years
earlier while he lost that first fight
he'd go on to become one of DC's most
prominent villains and an occasional
hero
when DC revived Captain Marvel in 1972
it was in a series called Shazam and by
1974 they'd been prohibited from
referring to their lead character as
Captain Marvel on the cover at all the
reason an upstart superhero publisher
called Marvel Comics had snatched up the
copyright on that name for a new
character they'd introduced in 1967.
there Captain Marvel was a space-faring
soldier of the cree race named Marvel
who had come to Earth on a mission of
conquest and decided to become a cosmic
hero instead in an interesting twist
Marvel was revamped in 1969 with a new
red costume with a big yellow Insignia
on the chest and a young sidekick Rick
Jones with whom he switched Bodies In A
Flash of light whenever a hero was
needed of course there would be other
versions of Captain Marvel that Marvel
Comics would make including one that
might be a bit more familiar to
movie-going audiences needless to say
the fact that both DC and Marvel were
publishing superheroes named Captain
Marvel caused no end of confusion
eventually when the DC Universe was
Rebooted with the new 52 in 2011 Billy
Batson's Alter Ego was re-christened as
Shazam when they revived Captain Marvel
in the 1970s DC licensed the character
from faucet Publications in 1991 however
DC made the Shazam family a permanent
part of their Universe acquiring the
rights to the character outright at the
same time veteran Creator Jerry Ordway
was assigned to reboot the character yet
again in the pages of a fully painted
graphic novel called The Power of Shazam
in addition to retelling Billy Batson's
origin the story also tied him more
closely to Black Adam who had his own
civilian identity Theo Adam a greedy
archaeologist who murdered Billy's
parents while on a dig released in 1994
the power of Shazam was an unqualified
success and led to the launch of a
monthly title of the same name the next
year Ordway would ride and provide
covers for the series and draw a fair
bit of it too with nearly 50 issues
published it was and is the longest
running Shazam series since 1954. after
the DC Universe was rebooted for the new
52 Shazam started appearing as a backup
story in the pages of Justice League in
addition to a new costume and a new
origin for Dr Savannah this version of
Billy Batson wasn't quite the wholesome
good-natured kid he'd been in the past
instead Jeff Johns and Gary Frank
reimagined him as far more bitter and
cynical than readers had seen before the
idea was that his initial suspicion and
self-interest would give way to a
genuine heroism and an affection for his
adopted family there was one other big
twist though in the pages of Flashpoint
the universe ending event that led to
the new 52 reboot breeders got a glimpse
of a version of Shazam who had split his
powers among six kids this in itself
wasn't a completely new idea Mary Batson
and Freddie Freeman had been turned into
Mary Marvel and Captain Marvel Jr
respectively the same way as had a few
other characters all the way back in the
Golden Age this time though Billy
decided to split his powers not just
with Mary and Freddy but with his Foster
siblings Darla Pedro and Eugene the
result is a whole team of Heroes with a
much more diverse cast than previous
versions of the Shazam family who will
all be appearing alongside each other in
the pages of the next Shazam title it
also feels a little reminiscent of a
very different superheroic captain
's greatest champion
way back in 1941 Captain Marvel made his
big screen debut in a republic picture
serial beating Max fleischer's animated
Superman cartoons to the theater by six
months and predating a live-action
Superman Cereal by seven years now in
2019 Billy Batson returns to the movies
in Shazam with Asher Angel as Billy
Batson Zachary Levi as Shazam and Mark
Strong as Dr Savannah the film sticks
pretty close to the 2012 version of the
hero weirdly enough while Dwayne The
Rock Johnson has been attached to the
project longer than nearly anyone else
he doesn't appear in Shazam he's been
cast as Black Adam in DC's Cinematic
Universe but Warner Brothers has
announced that they'll be featuring the
character in a Solo film before he
crosses paths with his old nemesis
we've come up with our own viewing order
for the dceu that we believe does the
best job of introducing you to the
characters building the universe and
getting you hyped for what happens next
so take a look at the right order to
watch every DC extended Universe movie
wonder woman takes place during World
War One which means that chronologically
it's the first film in the DC EU by a
good margin that's not the main reason
why we've selected it for our number one
spot though Wonder Woman is also the
best reviewed film in DC's lineup and
when you're beginning a lengthy movie
marathon like this it definitely helps
to start off on the right foot kicking
off with what's arguably the best movie
in the series will definitely give you
some motivation to keep watching if
things get a little rough I am
above average the film also does a great
job of introducing Wonder Woman as a
character which will give viewers the
Solid Ground they need to move forward
with her Ultra successful solo film and
her status as arguably the best part of
both Batman vs Superman and Justice
League
Wonder Woman is the face of the DC EU so
getting her most prominent role right up
front makes a lot of sense plus her
upbeat attitude and winning combination
of Hope and courage provides some
much-needed light before heading into
the Grimmer darker films
released in 2013 Man of Steel is the
film that started the DC EU franchise
but it didn't really do much to build
the universe around it there was no Nick
Fury style post-credits scene to what's
essentially a standalone film but it's
still hugely important to watch it early
on in your Marathon because everything
that comes after Builds on what happened
here plus well it's the movie that
introduces Superman Clark Kent's Alter
Ego is the most important character in
DC's lineup and his actions here
directly influence the rest of the films
and Man of Steel Superman has a
massively destructive battle against
fellow Kryptonian General Zod on the
streets of metropolis and witnessing the
level of Carnage that results motivates
both Batman and Lex Luthor to try and
put an end to him in Batman vs Superman
plus the world seeing the true threats
that are out there makes them desperate
enough to consider the idea of criminal
superheroes in Suicide Squad Man of
Steel might have kicked things off but
the movie that really put the universe
into the DC EU was Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice which picked up where
Superman's solo outing left off and
expanded its scope as fast as it could
not only does it deal with the Fallout
from Superman's battle with Zod it also
introduces Batman Wonder Woman and
through a series of short video clips
that's hilariously shoehorned in the
rest of the Justice League 2 and just in
case that wasn't enough it throws in the
mother boxes too as the macguffins that
will later feature heavily Injustice
League
in between all the World building are
the film's two main conflicts the
eponymous fight between Batman and
Superman and the big showdown between
doomsday and a united front to Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman with Lex
Luthor looming in the background of both
while doomsday is ultimately defeated
Superman is killed in the process which
has major ramifications down the line
of all the films in the DC EU Suicide
Squad seems like the one you could slide
in anywhere there are brief cameos from
Batman in The Flash but beyond that
there is not much connection to the rest
of the universe and the events of the
film are pretty self-contained look
closer however and it's clear that
Suicide Squad takes place at a very
specific moment Superman's death and
Batman vs Superman leads to the
government getting desperate for a new
way to deal with superpowered threats
someone needs to pick up the slack and
that's where the suicide squad comes in
composed of the kind of deadly criminals
like Harley Quinn deadshots and Killer
Croc who have proven they can go
toe-to-toe with the superheroes the team
is enlisted to fight the deadliest
battles in Superman's absence the film
also ends with Amanda Waller giving
Bruce Wayne information on the other
Heroes allowing him to assemble the
Justice League and since Superman
Returns to the land of the living
Injustice League it only makes sense to
watch Suicide Squad during the time when
he wasn't around
Aquaman came out after Justice League
but it makes a lot more sense to watch
it before you get into the DC eu's big
team up justice league is at best the
flawed movie with a rushed plot that
crams in too many characters to properly
introduce and the tone is all over the
place the film underperformed at the box
office and was unpopular with both
critics and fans alike which is probably
why Aquaman completely ignores the
events of that movie except for one
throwaway line Aquaman was a Bonafide
Blockbuster and the only DC EU movie so
far to earn over a billion dollars at
the worldwide box office with a sweeping
Adventure that plays out over big action
set pieces both on land and Under the
Sea it also does an excellent job of
introducing Aquaman to audiences much
like starting off with Wonder Woman
getting to know Aquaman and his element
here makes it much more satisfying to
see him again Justice League
congratulations you've made it to
Justice League this was meant to be DC's
equivalent to The Avengers but it simply
lacked the build up that led to its
Marvel movie counterpart The Avengers
had the benefits of two Iron Man movies
The Incredible Hulk Thor and Captain
America the First Avenger all
interconnected to introduce its roster
of characters and the world around them
Justice League happened much faster and
one of its preceding films Suicide Squad
was completely unrelated to the others
watch Aquaman first however and you
should be geared up to see the
established characters join forces in
Justice League even if it means some of
the Aquaman scenes in Justice League
feel a bit out of order
when you don't have to concentrate on
figuring out who all the characters are
it's a lot easier to enjoy the movie on
another level that familiarity with
characters from other films is what made
the Avengers work so well and mimicking
the formula with this DC EU viewing
order will make it a whole lot easier to
find the fun and Justice League's
over-the-top action
if the Grand Adventure in bright colors
of Aquaman marked a recalibration of the
dceu after Justice League then Shazam is
practically a full-on reboot there are
no characters from any other films aside
from a jokey Superman Cameo instead the
film uses the idea of a superhero
universe as background material to tell
its own story the story is much brighter
much funnier and much more fun than its
predecessors and also Embraces more of
the comic book weirdness that made the
Marvel movies work so well the film's
post-credits scene even features Mr mine
an evil talking caterpillar it's nearly
impossible to imagine something like
that happening in the ultra dark and
humorless world we saw in Batman vs
Superman with the DC eu's upcoming slate
composed of more colorful films like the
Harley Quinn LED girl gang team up bird
to prey the future of the DC EU looks to
be much brighter than what came before
since Shazam kicks off the DC eu's New
Era it's the perfect ending point to the
franchise's current lineup
it'd be The Showdown of the century but
could the mighty Adam really take on the
Man of Steel Dwayne Johnson faced an
eight-year struggle to bring Black Adam
to the big screen now Johnson's patience
and dedication is paid off in its first
four days at the box office Black Adam
brought in 67 million dollars
domestically becoming the best opening
weekend performance of any movie with
Johnson in the lead role notably the
character Johnson portrays Black Adam is
one of the most powerful in DC Comics of
course the biggest Buzz behind Black
Adam is Superman's brief Cameo at the
very end of the movie it's a match made
in heaven in the comic books both
characters possess superhuman strength
speed hearing healing and stamina but
the movie's tease of a showdown between
soups and mighty Adam has got fans
wondering who will ultimately win when
these two juggernauts come to blows in
the DC EU there's no one on this planet
that can stop me one critical difference
between Superman and Black Adam in the
comics is that Adam can discharge
lightning bolts as projectiles while
engaging his enemies in battle it might
not ever need to come to that though
because Black Adam has an immediate Edge
over Kalel the mighty Adam's most
significant unique advantage over the
last son of Krypton is that he is
Immortal Superman seems ageless but
Kalel does grow older albeit at a
prolonged rate due to the sun's effect
on his Kryptonian cells it might take
centuries or even longer but Clark Kent
will eventually succumb to death from
natural causes if a brouhaha between
these two super beings ever escalated
into a fight theoretically Black Adam
could just wait it out until Superman
Keels over from old age
since a millennia long wait does not
make for very good storytelling however
there must be a more immediate
determination of a winner for his part
Superman can put up one heck of a fight
his debut in Action Comics number one
back in 1938 saw Superman able to LEAP 1
8 of a mile with skin that could be
broken by nothing less than a bursting
Shell by contrast the Superman of more
recent days has been seen lifting
quintillions of tons single-handed
flying so fast that time moves backward
and punching holes in the fabric of
reality writers have gone back to the
Superman loses his powers well so many
times that it's become a full-blown
Trope mostly because it's hard to write
a high-stick story when your hero can't
be beaten and that might just be where
Black Adam comes into play while
everybody knows that Superman is
vulnerable to Kryptonite he has another
weakness that people often forget about
magic
in Superman number 14 The Man of Steel
was put under a trance by malevolent
fish people and Superman Vol 2 number 49
a piece of magical Kryptonite strips him
of his powers in Superman number 171 he
outright laments that his
invulnerability can't protect him from a
sorcerer's spell this brings us to Black
Adam Adam has gone through his own
Growing Pains over the years but one
aspect of his personality has remained
solid his powers are magical in nature
did you just catch a rocket they were
given to him by the same wizard who
turned Billy Batson into the world's
Mightiest mortal and they stem from the
abilities of ancient gods sometimes
Greeks sometimes Egyptian but always
very very powerful if Black Adam plans
on defeating Superman he should travel
to Smallville Kansas where kalel's
vessel crash landed on Earth and where
he may find green Kryptonite green K is
among the most common and Powerful
iterations of kryptonite because it can
weaken and kill the man of steel with
prolonged exposure if the mighty Adam
wants to take out Superman once and for
all though there's only one shade of
kryptonite he should bother searching
for gold Kryptonite the most formidable
weapon Black Adam or anyone else for
that matter could ever hope to wield
against Kal-El gold Kryptonite will
permanently strip Superman of all his
powers Black Adam will have to get up
close and personal to use it but gold K
is another potential way to Victory with
all the advantages Black Adam has over
the Man of Steel the simple truth
remains Superman is stronger if it comes
down to physical combat the mighty atom
will fall even inferior alternate
versions of Superman have bested Black
Adam in the comic books in Shazam volume
3 number 14 the evil Superboy Prime
easily defeats not only Black Adam but
all the Marvels on his own and that was
the second time Superboy Prime best of
the mighty Adam he also made quick work
of him during the Infinite Crisis
crossover event Ultraman kalel's
alternate darker half from Earth 3 ended
his fisticuffs with Black Adam by
breaking his jaw in Forever Evil number
three and don't think Superman will have
any problem dealing out punishment
against his new foe Cal has abandoned
his morality on multiple occasions to do
what is necessary to save the world and
those he loves an alternate reality
Kalel slaughtered Wonder Woman in 2004's
Superman Batman absolute power and the
Man of Steel wiped out the Joker Black
Canary Green Arrow and even Shazam in
the far-reaching Injustice Saga finally
in Man of Steel the first official
installment of the dceu's Big Screen
Adventures Superman is forced to break
General zod's neck to save a group of
civilians bottom line Superman is not
above killing although Dwayne Johnson
put in a lot of work to get Henry Cavill
back in the game the answer to this
question is simple given the right
conditions Black Adam would best
Superman in a fight funnily enough
however Johnson doesn't necessarily
agree in an interview with Jake's takes
he said we will create Black Adam for
him to be the most powerful and
Unstoppable force on this planet the
most powerful and Unstoppable force in
the entire universe has been on the
sidelines for too long so what's going
to happen when Superman and Black Adam
finally get their Showdown looks like
we'll just have to wait to find out
the suicide squad is by its very nature
a violent film the comic books the film
is based around Center on a task force
composed mostly of super villains forced
against their will by the cold-hearted
Amanda Waller to take on missions no one
in their right mind would want to do
oh yeah Waller's combatants are
criminals not Heroes at least not in the
traditional sense and each of them has
an explosive device implanted at the
base of their skulls in other words even
if someone from Waller's task force x
were to somehow survive their mission
there's still a chance while or might
just pop their head like a grave James
Gunn's latest adaptation of the team The
Suicide Squad goes all the way on the
gruesome and gory nature of the comic
book Source material in fact the entire
opening of the film introduces us to a
new character named Savant makes us care
about him connects him with characters
fans already know like Captain Boomerang
and Harley Quinn only to have Waller
blow his head off when he flees the
mission
in fact every single character other
than Harley and Rick Flagg dies during
the opening each death more horrific
than the last in short when James Gunn
says that there was a scene from The
Suicide Squad that Warner Brothers
thinks went too far when compared with
the entire Grizzly opening you know it's
pretty bad so what is the one scene gun
had to fight to keep in the film you're
supposed to be decisive and I've decided
they're usually a big bag of
when Rick flag is captured after the
disastrous first team's Beach assault
the second team led by Bloodsport is
sent on a mission to save flag Waller
tells Bloodsport that they are to kill
the dangerous people holding flag with
extreme prejudice causing Bloodsport and
Peacemaker to go on a competitive bloody
Rampage as they systematically wipe out
everyone in the camp there's just one
problem flag isn't a prisoner of war in
fact he's being cared for by a
resistance force fighting to bring Peace
and Freedom to the citizens of Corto
Maltese and that's who task force x just
killed oops it turns out this was the
scene Warner Brothers balked at when
asked if he got any pushback Gunn told
variety yeah I did during an early
screening for the suicide squad gun said
there were some Warner Brothers execs
who brought up is this the one place
that we go too far I think that's when I
added you know Amanda Waller explicitly
tells them to go into the camp and kill
everyone so they are following her
orders and she is in a way the
antagonist in the film based on fan
reaction though it seems that audiences
picked up what gun was putting down with
the scene while the scene of Bloodsport
and Peacemaker one-upping each other by
killing their allies in the quarter
maltesian resistance is certainly a
shocking and brutally ironic bit of
Ultraviolence that's kind of the point
The Suicide Squad is one of those films
where the protagonists aren't
necessarily the good guys in the grander
scheme of things a scene like the
massacre at the rebel Camp is a way to
remind the viewer that while they may be
rooting for these characters in the
moment there is a whole lot of moral
gray area to contend with at least
that's how fans on Reddit saw it in a
general discussion thread for the film
on the movies subreddit several viewers
shared their thoughts on the
controversial scene user Razer thought
instigated the discussion by writing
favorite scene was when the squad is
infiltrating the resistance camp and
Bloodsport and Peacemaker are trying to
outdo each other with flashy kills just
to find out they were accidentally
killing the good guys the whole time
that scene was a plus user keichuya
Mewtwo agreed adding that the scene 4 is
a necessary recalibration in the
viewer's perception they wrote just
reminding us that these are villains of
our superheroes ready to do anything for
their personal Ambitions for user Arma
104 the scene was also indicative of the
improvements that the suicide squad made
over the infamous 2016 attempt at
bringing the concept to screen they
wrote this is what impressed me most
about the movie the first one was
hell-bent on trying to make the
characters cool and edgy this one
they're doing the most vile evil and are
absolute dorks and morons
for bad guys it's what we do
The Suicide Squad is in theaters and
streaming on HBO Max now
a superhero quoting a warmongering vice
president a hilarious evil dance routine
and perhaps the worst Batman moment of
all time here are a few times that DC
movies made us cringe
it's probably fair to say that gallic
Dutch is not exactly recognized as one
of her generation's masters of the
theatrical Arts some might argue that's
okay after all her iteration of Wonder
Woman relies on physicality and Charisma
much more than spending the audience's
disbelief indeed when she does come off
as little disconnected that actually
helps her project a sense of other
worldliness but every once in a while
Godot delivers some good old-fashioned
bad acting her Infamous overwrought
reprimand of a rampaging Superman in
both the 2017 and the 2021 versions of
Justice League serves as a case in point
of course Wonder Woman's decision to
call Superman by his Kryptonian birth
name at this point seems odd in itself
seeing as hell basically nobody from
Earth calls him that
but the real shocker here is godot's
line read both Justice League movies
include different takes of Wonder
Woman's warning
Khalil no
kalal no
and neither of them are good this might
suggest that the writers ought to share
some of the blame for this particular
blunder but let's face it Godot is
hardly helping
this is a scene that'll be talked about
for decades but not for the reasons DC
once hoped in 2016's Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice Batman is about to
impale Superman on a Kryptonite Spear
and then
you're letting him kill Martha
him refers to Lex Luthor who has taken
Martha cantostage Martha as an abstract
concept provides a basis for thoughtful
analysis of gender and Zack Snyder's DCU
Phillips that said even though her
kidnapping provides Superman's
motivation at this point Martha barely
seems like she's in this movie at all
until
saved
Martha
this Cosmic coincidence forces Batman to
hesitate allowing enough time for Lois
Lane to show up and explain Luther's
evil plot and sure in some parallel
universe there may exist a version of
this scene that isn't cringe-worthy
after all the idea does make sense it's
just to shame the execution leaves so
much to be desired
when Vice President Dick Cheney left
office in 2009 his administration's
approval rating had sunk into the low
20s so should a beloved hero like Batman
parrots such a hugely divisive and
retired politician dawn of Justice seems
to think so
she has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and if we believe there's
even a one percent chance that he is our
enemy we have to take it as an absolute
certainty
somebody clearly thought this quote was
so apt that they even included it in the
film's trailer but folks who remember
Post 9 11 American politics might notice
that Batman borrowed an Infamous Cheney
quote there partly verbatim in 2003 the
X Veep had said if there's a one percent
chance that Pakistani scientists are
helping Al Qaeda build or develop a
nuclear weapon we have to treat it as a
certainty in terms of our response this
argument was used by Cheney in 2003 as
justification for the U.S invasion of
Iraq here Batman vs Superman puts a
widely disliked man's words about a
wildly unpopular war in the mouth of one
of the most popular heroes in all of
fiction whatever the intent for the
purpose of the story it feels like a
serious misfire though it's never stated
outright it's very heavily implied that
in Batman vs Superman Lex Luthor pees in
a jar and leaves it on a Podium as a
final screw you to Senator June Fitch
this happens just moments before a
suicide bomber kills her along with an
entire courtroom of people doesn't this
Juvenile and crass even for Jesse
eisenberg's bizarre take on Luther based
on his mannerisms and background this
version of Luther scans like a
combination of eisenberg's performance
in The Social Network and a mediocre
screenwriter who once made a YouTube fan
film about Superman even still you can't
help but wonder if the movie version of
Mark Zuckerberg would have come up with
a more elegant and sophisticated way to
mess with Senator Finch's Brain before
blasting her to Smithereens he did
invent Facebook after all
the version of Jonathan Kent portrayed
by Kevin Costner and Man of Steel is a
man who loves farming and hates rescuing
people when they're in trouble this
makes him a somewhat non-traditional
interpretation of Clark Kent's
foundational male role model who in
other takes on the Superman myth tends
to gently push Clark in a more
pro-saving people Direction
no ifs ands or buts about it the moment
when famously Invincible Clark Kent
stands by and watches his adopted Dad
run into a raging tornado to rescue the
family dog only to predictably die
horribly is very cringy obviously
Superman could rescue his paw and the
pooch very quickly and with minimal
effort but instead he just stands there
and does this
and if you think that's bad wait until
you hear Superman's Cry of exhausted
anguish immediately after offing Zod at
the end of the movie
but hey maybe this is just how Superman
reacts to bad stuff missed the bus
colors ran in the wash
out of milk
poor old Clark Kents just can't catch a
break
Barbara Minerva is one of the most
glaring missed opportunities in Wonder
Woman 1984. there have been a few
different versions of cheetah in the
comics but the Baseline of Barbara can
be summarized as the answer to the
question what if Indiana Jones was an
evil flesh-eating jungle cat but instead
of a physical and mental match for an
immortal Amazon princess Wonder Woman
1984 coughs up an awkward nerd who loses
her mind when she gets powers in the
molds of some of Joel Schumacher's
Batman villains when Barbara and Diana
meet Barbara's deeply envious of Diana
because something to do with her
self-esteem even though Barbara is also
a conventionally attractive woman with a
fancy archeology career that presumably
pays very handsomely indeed still at
least she looks good in her cheetah form
the general consensus on the two
versions of Justice League is that Zack
Snyder's revamped version of the movie
released in 2021 is a step up from the
2017 theatrical cut but that doesn't
mean the so-called Snyder cut is totally
free of cringe-worthy moments take for
instance the whole deal with Martha Kent
and Lois Lane after ma Kent finishes
telling Lois Lane that she can't grieve
over Superman's death forever Martha
leaves the apartment then suddenly
transforms into Jon Jones also known as
The Martian Manhunter Jones in his dceu
debut then transforms again into General
Calvin swanwick who you may remember for
Man of Steel Martian Manhunter never
interacts directly with any Justice
League members until well after the
major events of the film have wrapped up
he comes across as totally unconnected
to the plot and feels shoehorned in for
the purpose of showing the audience yet
another familiar intellectual property
furthermore he raises some befuddling
Quest the film never addresses for one
was Terry Lennox who plays General
swanwick playing Jon Jones all the way
back in Man of Steel or did Jon replace
that guy at some point that's not the
only problem with the scene either
setting aside whether you accept the
idea that Lois would completely fall
apart after Superman's demise the kind
of serious clinical depression she is
suffering from isn't the sort of thing
that gets resolved by a pep talk from
your almost mother-in-law all in all a
decent scene for fan service but not so
much for anything else
in one of the most talked about
additions to Justice League's 2021
Schneider cut the film's plot flashes
forward to a potential future one in
which Batman and a cohort of costume
Pals wander through a Mad Max style
Wasteland it soon becomes clear that
this gang includes the Joker played by
Jared Leto reprising his Suicide Squad
role a subsequent conversation between
Batman and the Joker dumps the
exposition of their relationship
basically Batman can never kill the
Joker because they complete each other
or something it's the usual song and
dance but then Joker says this
he won't kill me
I'm your best friend besides
who's gonna give you a reach around oh
boy that's right this ain't your
grandpa's Joker this one is dark and
scary and kinda homophobic too Eat Your
Heart Out Zach Galifianakis and sure
some folks like the Joker stuff and Zack
Snyder's Justice League all power to
them but you'd also be forgiven for
thinking it plays like a 13 year old
read The Killing Joke saw the Dark
Knight and then decided to write a
Batman Joker scene that was the edgiest
thing to ever have an edgy night in
Edgeville of course the scene also makes
basically no sense and adds nothing to
the larger context of the movie but it
is at least noteworthy for its
Vindication of Joel Schumacher who is no
longer responsible for the worst Batman
moment of all time
thanks to the runaway success of James
Gunn's 2021 The Suicide Squad the David
Ayer directed original Suicide Squad is
likely to fade away Into Obscurity still
we'll always have the memories like
these early promotional Stills for the
film that set Jared Leto up to fail
miserably as the successor to Heath
Ledger's turn as the clown Prince of
Crime before you realized what you were
looking at you might have been forgiven
for wondering why air had chosen to
promote his Suicide Squad movie with
that guy who got kicked out of the mall
for taking his shirt off in Spencer's or
maybe you wondered why Jared Leto had
started a metal core band but then the
horrible truth dawned oh man that's
supposed to be the Joker it wasn't a
great moment
here's a fun fact for you belly dancing
is not intimidating if you have ever
been to a belly dancing demonstration
you'll notice that the performers in no
way intend to frighten the audience so
when the mind's behind Suicide Squad
needed something for enchantress to do
to indicate that some evil as heck magic
was taking place why did they land on
this it's clear that somebody at Warner
Brothers thought audiences would react
better to a runway model dancing in her
underwear rather than say anything that
actually made sense but this is suicide
squad's main antagonist someone who is
supposed to be a big bad reality
destroying the super villain shouldn't
she be doing anything more disturbing
than shaking her hips to some medium
quality CG effects
honestly enchantress this whole deal in
Suicide Squad feels like somebody in
charge was working overtime to appeal to
the teenage male segment of the audience
which would explain what they did to
Harley Quinn too
thanks to the advancement of Science and
Technology it's more or less common
amongst human beings to carry around
what is essentially a computer in their
pockets amazing right and yet Hollywood
still seems unable to edit one mustache
off one guy in one movie
back in 2017 a tragic family emergency
forced original director Zack Snyder to
leave the production of what became the
theatrical cut of Justice League the now
notorious John Sweden took over from
there to basically nobody's Satisfaction
by the time the weed in helmed reshoots
began however Henry Cavill had grown a
mustache for his part in Mission
Impossible Fallout this meant that the
Justice League special effects team had
to digitally erase cattle's facial hair
in post-production by the time Justice
League hit theaters the extensive
reshoots and digital edits had been
widely reported in the media so it's
hard to say if anyone would have noticed
the change if they weren't looking for
it sadly it happened to be the case that
everybody was in fact looking for a
digitally altered upper lip that came
straight out of Bizarro world as a
result everybody did notice it and the
ensuing laughter could be heard all
around the world
foreign